[Music]  in the woods today  la discovered a charming little land  work but that secretary place to bury  our pets to remember them which seems  scary but it's not perfectly natural  just like dying is natural whole town's  been using this place for generations  folks make a kind of ritual out of it  it's not some campfire story so these  are the trees up there they're warnings  the local tribes carved and before they  fled they feared that place there's  something up there something that dates  way back  those would - something else something  that cat was dead  you bring these things back  [Music]  I know what you're thinking of doing but  they don't come back the same what's  going on Thank You daughter I should  never have shown you that place your  child is not the only thing that will  come back  you have a second chance sometimes dead  is better  [Music]